sixteen-year-old tabitha couldn't wait
to get jabbed
having it in the holidays means immunity
builds before school starts and at this
center in york teenage turnout is high
i've been excited to get the vaccine for
a while obviously just to be protected
if you're vulnerable like me then
it's just better to get it and just to
be safe being at school people be having
to go home because other people have had
it
it's better getting a vaccine because i
know that i'm safe
all 16 and 17 year olds in england have
now been invited to book a jab and this
video is a reminder why they should
i was fit and healthy and literally no
conditions i was doing exercise
young people suffering the effects of
long covid
i genuinely thought i might die
including 25 year old megan ill in
january and still struggling now the
tiredness and the fatigue was kind of
the biggest giveaway there were days
where i didn't want to get out of bed
where i hurt all over good boy let's go
megan and monty used to enjoy long walks
now she only manages a few minutes proof
she says why young adults should get the
jab even if you manage to fight off the
main virus without kind of breaking
stride you might find like i did
six eight months down the line that that
you're sat exhausted and hurting
at which point you you will really wish
that you'd protected yourself at the
start
infection rates are currently highest
among younger people that's why there's
a drive to get them jabbed
we've looked very carefully at this
we're seeing enough serious cases in
this age group in healthy 16 and 17 year
olds
and we're seeing good safety data after
the first dose of the vaccine to
reassure us that there's a clear benefit
over risk
ratio and that this is the right
decision that 16 and 17 year olds will
benefit uh strongly from receiving this
vaccine
but what about even younger children
there are still questions about whether
all 12 to 15 year olds should be jabbed
particularly with back to school around
the corner for now that age group isn't
being vaccinated but scientists say the
decision is under constant review
with 16 and 17 year olds joining the
cues every injection should help bring
down infections and help protect us all
against the virus laura bundock sky news
in leatherhead in surrey